I would love to do another Christopher
Guest movie I know he's doing television
now he's doing something on HBO that I'm
sure will be fabulous um you know I
don't know your your your guess is as
good as mine I hope we will do something
again and I hope it's soon I mean I can
wait I mean it can be 10 years I don't
care but I just want to do it
you know what i think is my favorite
moment and and to show you how selfless
i am it's a moment i'm not in its the
moment where the kids are on stage in
the pilot episode and they sing their
first don't stop believing and how raw
it was and how for all of them was the
first time they felt like they were in a
group that supported them and they were
finally making music they were finally
doing a number they cared about and I
think at that moment those kids really
and as the actors to anything are the
thing in the television really gel
oh hello lon Jane Lynch here thank you
for enjoying the movie uh for the most
part I record it alone which is a very
very lonely thing and then they brought
in Jack for two sessions Jack McBrayer
and it was an absolute joy and rich
really encouraged us to improvise our
director rich more um and I know that
Sarah Silverman and John Riley work
together a lot and that is unusual for
an animated film will usually do it in
isolation for the most part but I was
very grateful for the couple of sessions
i had with Jack and I know Sarah and Jon
adored there's and I think you can see
it in the movie I'm hi Ellie I'm Jane
and I'm a woman and I don't see any
obstacles there were obstacles they were
they happen behind my back you know I
mean there are given circumstances in
the business that I don't um about being
the woman that I don't think about at
all I don't bother with I think that
when you view the world and the business
urine is like it filled with obstacles
and you know you're you're you know
you're you're not going you're going to
have to work harder than men I think you
just set yourself up so i would let all
of those notions ago
Ava you know what advice I give now is
just do do do do and I did say do do
that's how I learned that's how I found
what I was good at have do not have
preconceived notions do not turn
anything down and as I always say you
have a caveat to that except for porn
probably not in your best interest you
know I don't have any advice like Oh get
an agent get the your pictures taken by
this person study this playwright go to
this acting teacher you know you have to
carve your own path for yourself and you
know I thought when I was younger that
somebody should come down from the
heavens and show me how to do this but
that's not how it works you have to find
your own way
you